in this video we're going to take a look
at bakago's hero name
which has finally been revealed in my
academia he previously tried to call
himself king explosion murderer
but after that was rejected he's been
pretty much tight-lipped about his real
hero name
ever since during his internship with
best genius
the number three hero told him that his
hero name should reflect his desires and
embody someone who bakugou wants to be
it's for that reason that i personally
never wanted it to be ground zero
which was probably the most popular fan
hero name for back ago
but whilst it undeniably sounded cool
for me there was
it didn't really represent anything
besides destruction you know there
wasn't much more to it
on the other hand bakugou's real hero
name which has been leaked
is way more suited to what genus was
saying but without further ado i won't
keep you waiting any longer
bakugo's hero name is dynamite this is
an
epic pun from harakoshi as the name is
not just referring to bakago's explosion
quirk
but when you spell it out you know it's
a clear reference to all might as well
bakago desires to be the undisputed
number one hero
in the same way that all might used to
be and back in the endeavor agency arc
bakugou made some interesting comments
that partially explain
why he chose this name in his words his
explosions can pull off anything he
wants them to
but he acknowledged that a strong quirk
is not enough to make him the strongest
person
to reach the summit like almighty did
you need a lot of things
but the defining feature that stands out
to me is all my
relentless need to save everyone
remember how during the usj attack
the only reason all might wasn't there
at the beginning is because he used up
all his power that morning
saving people on the way to work like
the guy just literally could not help
himself
when we compare this to baka go he was
less concerned with the
saving aspect of being a hero and he was
more interested in defeating villains
with his quirk this was displayed pretty
early on when he got a grand total of
zero rescue points during the ua
entrance exam
which was the lowest of any student
we're aware of but at the same time he
also got the highest amount
of points for destroying the robots so
you can see he had different priorities
from someone like all might
because we all know if all might took
that exam he would have had way more
rescue points than that
whereas deku has always been about
saving bakugou has historically been
about winning and beating the bad guys
but recently he's been turning into
someone who perhaps could care equally
about both those things
major spoilers ahead but his sacrifice
to save deku in chapter 285
was the embodiment of his ideal self
bakugou could have died trying to save
deku in this moment
but he went for it anyway because you
know because his priority was saving
deku
regardless of what happened to him
actions like this are exactly what we
would expect
from someone with the word might in
their name which is why i think this is
the perfect hero name and
you know it was it was great to reveal
it only after this moment
dynamite is an awesome hero name in my
opinion and i like how both bakugou
and kiroshima have hero names that
directly emulate
their idols let me know what you guys
think down below
is dynamite the right name for bakugo or
would you have preferred ground zero or
cat chan or something like that
i think no matter what name he chose you
know not everyone is gonna love it
but me personally i think it's perfect
that's everything from me for this
particular video
but be sure to turn on notifications
because there will be more stuff coming
including a reaction to the latest
popularity polls
and also uh what else was that oh yeah
that was the
leaks for chapter 293 i might be doing
that today or tomorrow but it is
definitely coming so yeah be sure to
have your notifications
on until the next one peace out